Tulsi gabbard served in the body that
zielinski addressed tonight she also
formed presidential candidate currently
an Army Reserve officer she joins us
tonight with three action Congressman
thank you so much for coming on you
thanks this makes me worried on many
levels but as a process question
everyone in that room members of
Congress both Republican and Democrats
seem so seized by emotion that you're
wondering like where the wise people
making decisions in the long-term
interest of the United States I didn't
see any of them
yeah I was thinking the same thing as I
was watching that speech and it really
it really is kind of the manifestation
in front of our very eyes of a whole lot
of hypocrisy because you have the Biden
administration's whole foreign policy is
essentially based on democracies and
autocracies we've got to divide the
world between these two categories and
the U.S is going to lead the charge for
democracies to defeat the autocracies
and so they have said hey Ukraine is a
thriving democracy and zelinski is this
hero that is protecting this democracy
which is why Biden says we'll do
everything within our power to support
him and oh by the way we're going to
send almost a 100 billion of American
taxpayer dollars to go and support this
defense of democracy but when you
actually look at what zelenski's
democracy is you see uh no freedom of
the press he has shut down any media
that he does not control his government
does not control he has gotten political
opposition arrested made sure that
that's happened as you mentioned he's
shut down the biggest Ukraine Church in
the country and and I found this quote
today he has actually threatened to
punish quote any Christian caught
worshiping in unapproved ways so this is
the Democracy that they are saying well
we need all of your money our money
taxpayer dollars to go and defend this
is their shining example of democracy
it's no surprise then when we look at
what's happening here at home Tucker and
it's no surprise how we see the
political and power elite so easily and
willing to undermine our own democracy
undermine our own freedoms abusing their
power to achieve their own political
interests because they look to
zielinski's democracy and they see a
reflection and an opportunity for
themselves I just don't understand
members of Congress could know that this
guy is arresting Christian pre-seizing
churches Banning an entire denomination
and not some it's not Scientology this
is like an ancient denomination how can
they endorse that I don't understand
they're Americans like what is this
I I think it shows a pure dereliction of
Duty frankly on so many of these members
of Congress from both parties who are so
hooked into and controlled by the war
machine in Washington the
military-industrial complex that they
will sit there you know they they took a
pledge to uphold our constitution to
support and defend the safety security
and freedom of the American people and
yet they're just sitting there clapping
and cheering on this guy who uses fancy
words like democracy and freedom and
aren't looking at the facts of what's
really going on and have no idea where
our taxpayer dollars are going and as
you said could not Define what is our
objective that serves the interests of
the American people it's it's scary how
irrational it is it actually rewards me
I appreciate your coming on Congressman
Tulsi gabbard thank you subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight